Antrittsbesuch bei der Führungsakademie
der Bundeswehr Offiziere will der
Bundesverteidigungsminister hier für die
Zeitenwende gewinnen und um ihre
Nachsicht
bitten viele dieser Veränderung werden
eben nicht so funktionieren wie das
Licht angeht wenn ich den Schalter
drücke es braucht Zeit es braucht Geduld
damit die Entscheidung richtig getroffen
und umgesetzt werden könen doch die
Weltlage erlaubt diese Geduld nicht nach
wie vor der Krieg in der Ukraine der
Konflikt um Bergkarabach schickt
Menschen auf die Flucht drogeberärden
Serbiens an der Grenze zum Kosovo im
Sahel folgt einputsch dem nächsten im
Südchinesischen Meer wächst die Gefahr
eines Kriegs zwischen China und den USA
und nun der unkalkulierbare Krieg im
Nahen Osten immer öfter werden Konflikte
militärisch ausgetragen die Zeitenwende
auf dem
Prüfstand Besuch des Kanzlers bei der
Einheit die künftig natoverbände sicher
an die Ostflanke geleiten soll eine
erste strukturelle Veränderung der
Streitkräfte hin zu Landes und
bündnisverteidigung dennoch ein Umdenken
in den Köpfen scheint bislang nicht
stattgefunden zu haben wie bislang
scheut die Politik militärische Macht
mitzudenken und whrhaftigkeit zu
demonstrieren um unseren Gegnern denn
das sind veritable Gegner die wir haben
auch wirklich deutlich zu machen dass
wir bereit sind uns auch wirklich mit
allen Mitteln zu verteidigen und diese
politische Botschaft gibt es in
Deutschland ja überhaupt gar nicht
sondern es ist eine Botschaft der
Konfliktvermeidung ein Mentalitätswandel
ein neues Denkmuster unbequem und dann
ist da ja noch die deutsche Geschichte
muss sie uns skeptisch machen
hinsichtlich militärischer Macht nein
sagt der langjährige Befehlshaber der
US-Armee in
Europa ihr verliert diese moralische
Autorität die ihr euch mit der
Aufarbeitung eurer Vergangenheit
erarbeitet habt sofern ihr sie nicht
dazu nutzt um weitere Konflikte zu
verhindern ich bin es leid nie wieder
von den Deutschen zu hören ohne dass Sie
sicherstellen es wird nie wieder
passieren sicherstellen mit der
Bundeswehr noch immer fehlt es ihr an
geldgerät und Personal nicht
verteidigungsfähig ist sie Strukturen
müssen reformiert werden auch die
Beschaffung doch vor der ganz großen
Reform Schut Pistorius zurück es wird
gedreht an kleinen Rädchen es verbessert
sich auch was man kann Pistorius nicht
Untätigkeit vorwerfen das wä würde
völlig fehlgehen aber die Frage ist
reicht der Hebel aus den er ansetzt da
würde ich sagen nein in diesen Tagen das
erste gemeinsame Militärmanöver der EU
eher klein und sehr spät gemeinsam
könnten die Europäer ein Machtfaktor
sein doch äten und Eitelkeiten
verhinderten bislang eine europäische
Verteidigungs und rüstungsgemeinschaft
Zeitenwende hin oder her so sind es
erneut die Amerikaner die zwei
Flugzeugträger jetzt in den Nahen Osten
schicken nicht die
Europäer uns fehlt hier auch wirklich
der militärische Nachdruck mit dem wir
unsere Botschaft beispielsweise an die
risbollah oder an den Iran oder an
andere terroristische Organisation
verbreiten könnten und am Ende ist es
schlicht der politische Wille der in
vielen Hauptstädten fehlt leider auch
wie ich finde in Deutschland 19 Monate
Zeitenwende viel hat sich seither
verändert zu wenig angesichts der
Weltlage mir kommt es so vor als wenn
Boris bistorius und oloff Scholz auf der
Brücke der Titanic stehen den Eisberg
sehen und sagen na ja wir könnten
vielleicht 5° steuerword gehen wollen
wir mal die rudeanlage nicht überfordern
von diesem Schiff weil wer weiß Ruder
kann abbrechen wenn man in die harlage
geht under sage ich nein dieses Risiko
müsste eingehen sonst krachen wir voll
in den Eisberg rein es braucht eine neue
whrhaftigkeit im Denken und im Handeln
viel Zeit bleibt
nicht nicht schnell genug nicht
entschieden genug so kann man die Kritik
glaube ich zusammenfassen und bei mir
ist der Bundesverteidigungsminister
Boris Pistorius schönen guten Abend gen
Abend Frau sie haben den Titanic
Vergleich gehört und der Vorwurf der
ging unter anderem auch an sie deswegen
frage ich jetzt mal ganz direkt warum
nicht mehr Tempo
viel mehr Tempo geht gar nicht also ich
finde ja es schön dass es so viele gut
gemeinte Ratschläge aus allen Richtungen
gibt auch von militärhistorikern und von
anderen tatsächlich ist aber die Aufgabe
so groß und wir haben so viel zu tun
gerade dass man sich nicht mit all
diesen Ratschlägen auseinandersetzen
kann Tempo ist das eine das legen wir
vor ich nenne nur mal das Beispiel dass
wir bis zum Ende diesen Jahres über zwei
Drittel des Sondervermögens bereits
vertraglich gebunden haben wenn das
hätte uns vor halben Jahr niemand
zugetraut das Problem ist nur die
Verträge sorgen noch nicht unmittelbar
für Produktion und Lieferung dafür
braucht es wieder Zeit gleichzeitig
haben wir Strukturen verändert wir
machen Tempo wo es geht aber 30 Jahre
West 30 Jahre Friedensdividende 30 Jahre
ohne Wahrschauer Pakt als Bedrohung auf
der anderen Seite haben dazu geführt
dass die Bundeswehr übrigens wie andere
Streitkräfte auch nicht in dem Zustand
sind wie sie sonst gewesen wären das
kann man nicht in 19 Monaten aufholen
weder durch Produktion noch durch
Beschaffung noch durch anderes unser
maßst muss sein so schnell wie es irgend
geht und auch so energisch wie es irgend
geht sie sagen man kann das so schnell
nicht aufholen jetzt betonen sie aber
selber auch bei jeder Gelegenheit wie
bedrohlich die Weltlage jetzt momentan
ist und wie groß die Instabilität die da
heranwächst braucht es da nicht gerade
jetzt deshalb einen Mentalitätswandel
der dann auch me zu mehr Tempo beiträgt
da gebe ich ihn völlig recht wir
brauchen einen Mentalitätswechsel in der
Truppe da ist er im vollem Gange das
merke ich z.B wenn wir über die Brigade
lown sprechen wir brauchen ihn den BMVg
da haben wir die Weichen gestellt wir
brauchen ihn aber auch auch in der
gesamten Gesellschaft und wir brauchen
ihn auch in der Politik die
Bundesregierung hat sich klar bekannt
zum 2% Ziel wird das ab
2728 wenn das Sondervermögen
aufgebraucht sein wird bewerkstelligen
das ist nämlich zentral damit wir
dauerhaft in Beschaffung investieren
können aber ganz wichtig auch der
Mentalitätswechsel in der Gesellschaft
ist richtig wir müssen uns wieder an den
Gedanken gewöhnen dass die Gefahr eines
Krieges in Europa drohen könnte und das
heißt wir müssen kriegstüchtig werden
wir müssen wehrhaft sein und die
Bundeswehr und die Gesellschaft dafür
aufstellen die Ernstfälle häufen sich
und ganz aktuell schauen wir mit Sorge
nach Israel die Armee verstärkt dort
gerade ihren Einsatz im Gazastreifen
manche Beobachter sprechen schon von der
Bodenoffensive wie sehr verschärft das
ihrer Einschätzung nach die Gefahr einer
weiteren Eskalation dort das ist schwer
abzuschätzen das hängt vor allenen davon
ab wonach es gerade aussieht dass die
Israelis tatsächlich so besonnen und mit
einzelnen Schritten vorgehen
gleichzeitig immer wieder auch
humanitäre Möglichkeiten eröffnen wie
das freie schalten der Wasserleitung
oder aber auch das M Gruppen wie die
hbollah oder der Iran anders sehen ja
das ist aber gerade der Kern des
Konflikts hier geht es um das
Selbstverteidigungs und das
Existenzrechts Israel und Deutschland
gehört hier eindeutig zu den die
uneingeschränkt Ja sagen zu diesem Recht
und deswegen ist es unsere Aufgabe an
der Seite Israels zu stehen und
gleichzeitig unseren Einfluss soweit er
da ist und geltend gemacht werden kann
dafür einzusetzen dass es keine weitere
Eskalation gibt sie sagen unseren
Einfluss die deutsche staatsraon
gebietet ja die kte Unterstützung
Israels was bedeutet das denn für sie
konkret als Verteidigungsminister das
bedeutet zunächst mal dass dann wenn
unsere israelischen Freunde
Unterstützung anfordern erfragen ob im
Sanitätsbereich oder auch im
Materialbereich das wird alles tun was
wir können um Sie dabei zu unterstützen
und wenn es zu einer weiteren Eskalation
kommt ist sind das auch die Schritte das
ist die Grenze was sie bereit wären zu
geben wir legen keine Grenze fest wir
entscheiden dann wenn wenn die
jeweiligen Entwicklungsschritte sich
abzeichnen und die Israelis mit den wir
regelmäßig im aus a sind aussta sind
sich melden sie haben in einem
Gastbeitrag in der Welt geschrieben wir
sind in der Pflicht eine klare Botschaft
nach Iran und an die hbollah zu senden
wir haben jetzt von der natoexertin eben
im Beitrag gehört dafür fehlt uns der
militärische
Nachdruck ja das stimmt der der mag im
Augenblick fehlen aber wir arbeiten ja
gerade mit Nachdruck daran die natopläne
werden gerade sind erstellt worden die
regionalen Pläne folgen wir stellen uns
an der Ostflanke auf und natürlich das
habe ich oft betont muss unser
Engagement in der Welt sichtbarer werden
als das bislang der Fall war z.B im
Indopazifik und nach an anderer Stelle
und da sind die natoopartner tatsächlich
auch ungeduldig wir haben gerade den
ehemaligen NATO Oberbefehlshaber gehört
im Beitrag der ganz deutlich gesagt hat
dass nie wieder gilt nur dann wenn
Deutschland auch bereit ist militärisch
für ein nie wieder zu sorgen und da
stimme ich ihm zu denn das ist genau der
Weg den wir eingeschlagen haben mit dem
100 Milliarden Euro Sondervermögen mit
der Zeitenwende mit all dem was wir
jetzt gerade tun aber noch mal das alles
lässt sich was in 30 Jahren verbockt
worden ist sorry wenn ich das so sage
und runtergewirtschaftet worden ist
nicht in 19 Monaten wieder einholen und
wann sind wir dann soweit so schnell wie
es irgendwie geht wir werden ich würde
mal sagen Ende des Jahrzehnts in 3 4 5
Jahren wahrscheinlich schon völlig
anders daastehen und wir sind heute
schon nach wie vor auch wenn das manche
nicht glauben wollen eine der stärksten
Streitkräfte innerhalb der NATO in
Europa und derweil sind die Krisen vor
unserer Tür und kommen zum Teil auch
näher sie werden das weiter beobachten
wie wir auch nicht nur beobachten
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch vi dan